in the last video we figured out the
probability of getting exactly three
heads oh when we have five flips of a
fair coin what i want to do in this
video is think about it in a slightly
more general way we're still going to
assume we have a fair coin although
we'll shortly see we don't have to make
that assumption but what i want to do is
figure out the probability of getting k
heads
k heads
in n flips in n flips
flips
of
the fair coin of the fare
of the fair coin
so the first thing to think about is
just how many possibilities there are
where there's going to be n flips
they're going to be n flips so literally
the first flip second flip third flip
all the way to the nth flip and this is
a fair coin each of these there's a each
each of these there's two equally likely
possibilities so the total number of
possibilities going to be 2 times 2
times 2 n times
so this is going to be equal to 2 to the
nth possibilities
two to the nth possibilities
now let's think about how many of those
equally likely these are all equally
likely possibilities this is a fair coin
let's think about how many of those
equally likely possibilities involve
involve k heads
involve k heads
well just like we did for the case where
we had we were thinking about three
heads we thought think about three heads
we say well look where the first of
those k heads the first of those k heads
how many different how many different
buckets could it fall into
well the first of the k heads could fall
into five into n different buckets right
it could be the first flip second flip
all the way to the nth flip
then the second of those k heads we
don't know exactly how many k is
we'll have n minus one possibilities
n minus one possibilities and then the
third of those k heads will have n minus
two possibilities since two of the spots
are already taken up and we would do
this until we have essentially accounted
for all of the k heads so this will go
down all the way to so this we will we
will
multiply the number of things we're
multiplying is going to be k one for
each of the k heads so this is one two
three and then you're going to go all
the way to n
minus k
minus 1. and you could try this out in
the case of 5. when n was 5 and k was 3
this resulted in 5 times 4
times and actually we just had to go
times 3 and actually that was this term
right over here so i'm doing a case that
is a little bit longer where k is a
slightly larger number because this
right over here is
5 minus 2 that is this one over here so
let me actually let me just not to
confuse you let me write it like this
let me write it like this
so you'll have n spots for that first
head and -1 spots for that second head
and then you keep going and you're going
to have a total of these k
k things you're multiplying and that
last one is going to be is going to have
n minus
n minus k minus 1 possibilities and now
hopefully it'll map a little bit better
to the one where we had five flips and
three heads because here there there was
five possibilities for the first head
four possibilities for the second head
and then n is five five minus two you
had three possibilities for the last
head so this actually works this is the
number of spots where or the number of
ways that we could put that we can stick
those heads in those or that we can
stick we can
put three heads into five different
possible buckets now just like the last
video we don't want to over count things
because we don't care about the order we
don't want to differentiate we don't
want to differentiate we don't want to
differentiate one ordering of heads and
i'm just going to use these letters to
differentiate the different heads we
don't want to differentiate this
from this
heads
a heads b or any of the other orderings
of this so we need to do is we need to
divide this we need to divide this
number so that we don't count all of
those different orderings we need to
divide this by the different ways that
you can order k things the different
ways that you can order k things so if
you have k things so
you know one thing two things all the
way to k things how many ways can you
order it
well the first thing can be in k
different positions
k different positions or maybe i'll do
it like this
maybe i'll i'll do it thing one i'll
call t for thing thing one
thing two
thing three all the way to thing k how
many different ways can you order it
well thing one can be in k different
positions then k thing two
will be in k minus one positions and
then all the way down to the last one is
only going to have one position so this
is going to be k
times k minus one
times k minus two all the way down all
the way down
to one
and in the example where we had three
heads in five flips was three times two
all the way down to one three times two
times one and so is there a simpler way
that we can write this well this
expression right over here
this expression right over here this is
the same thing as k factorial and if you
haven't ever heard of what a factorial
is it's exactly this thing right over
here k factorial literally means k times
k minus 1
times k minus 2
k minus 2 all the way down to 1. so for
example
2 factorial is equal to 2 times 1. 3
factorial is equal to 3 times 2 times 1
4 factorial is equal to 4 times 3 times
2 times 1. so and it's actually a fun
thing to play with factorials get large
very very very very fast so anyway this
denominator right over here can be
rewritten as k factorial
this right over here can be rewritten as
k factorial and is there any way to
rewrite this numerator in terms of
factorials so if we wrote if we were to
write n factorial so let me see how we
can write this if we were to write n
factorial get some real estate over here
so n factorial would be equal to n times
n minus 1 times n minus 2 all the way
down all the way down to 1. all the way
down to 1. that's kind of what we want
we just want the first k terms of it we
just want the first k terms of it so
what if we divide this
by
so let's divide this
by n minus k factorial
so n minus k
factorial so let's think about what that
is going to do that if we have n minus k
factorial
that is the same thing as we have to do
a little bit of algebraic manipulation
right over here that is the same thing
as
n minus k
n minus k
times n minus k minus 1
n minus k minus 1
minus 1 times n minus k
times n minus k
minus 2 all the way down to 1. and what
i want when you when you divide these
the 1 is going to cancel out and what
you may or may not realize and you can
you can work out the math is everything
is going to cancel out here until you're
just left with up here you're just left
everything from n times n minus 1 to n
minus k minus 1
because this if you if you if you if you
expand this out or if you if you
distribute this negative number this is
the same thing as n minus k plus 1. so n
minus k plus 1 is the integer that's one
larger than this right over here so if
you were to divide it out this would
cancel with something up here this would
cancel with something up here this would
cancel with something up here and what
you're going to be left with is exactly
this thing over here and if you don't
believe me if you don't believe me we
can actually try it out so let's think
about what 5 factorial
what 5 factorial
over
5 minus 3 factorial is going to be over
5 minus 3 factorial so this is going to
be five times four times three times two
times one so all of that stuff up there
all the way down to one
over five minus three is two over two
factorial two times one
two cancels with two one cancels with
one you don't have to worry about that
and you're just left with five times
four times three exactly what we had up
here
five times
five times four times three and so in
general if you wanted to figure out the
number of ways to stick two things in
five chairs and you don't care about
differentiating between those two things
you're going to have this expression
you're going to have you're going to
have this expression right over here
which is the same thing as this right
over here so you're going to have n
factorial
over
n minus k factorial and then you're
going to divide it by this expression
right over here which we already said is
the same thing as k factorial so you're
also going to divide it by k factorial
and then you have a generalized way of
figuring out the number of ways the
number of ways you can stick two things
or the number of ways actually i should
say the numbers you can stick k things
in n different buckets k heads and n
different flips
and so and another way of writing and
this is actually a generalized formula
for binomial coefficients so another way
to write this is the number of ways
the number of ways given that you have
given that you have n buckets given that
you have n buckets you can put k things
in them without having to differentiate
it or another way to think about it is
if you have n
n buckets or n flips and you want to
choose k of them and you want to choose
k of them to be heads or you want to
choose k of them in some way but you
want to don't want to differentiate so
all of these are generalized ways for
binomial coefficients
so going back to the original problem
what is the probability what is the
probability of getting k heads and n
flips of the fair coin well there's two
to the n equally likely possibilities so
let's write this down so the probability
of 2 to the n equally likely
possibilities and how many of those
possibilities result in exactly k heads
well we just figured that out in during
this video that's the number of
possibilities so n factorial over k
factorial times n minus k factorial now
it probably is a okay idea to memorize
this but i'll just tell you frankly you
know one the only reason why i still
know how to do this 20 years after first
seeing it or whatever i first saw it is
that i actually just like to reason
through it every time i like to just
reason through okay i've got five flips
three of them need to be heads the first
of those heads can be in five different
buckets and the next in four different
buckets the next one three different
buckets and then of course i don't want
to differentiate between all of the
different ways i don't want to
differentiate between all of the
different ways
that i can rearrange three different
things so i have to make sure that i
divide it by that i divide it by 3
factorial by 3 times 2 times 1. i want
to make sure that i divide it by all of
the different ways that i can arrange
three different things